مخاوف من ان يغرد تويتر خارج سربي وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي بعد ان كان من ابرز
منصه المستخدمه على مستوى العالم اثر
التعديلات المستمره التي يطلقها الملك
الجديد الي ماسك اصابع قليله مرت على
استحواذ الملياردير الامريكي على الطائر
الازرق لينقلب الوضع راسنا على عقب اخر
قرارات ماسك كان عوده الموظفين العاملين
عن بعد منذ انتشار فايروس كورونا الى
المكاتب لمده لا تقل عن 40 ساعه اسبوعيا
في رساله بالبريد الالكتروني حذر ماسك
الناجين من موجه التسريحات الهائله من
اوقات عصيبه قد تعصف بتويتر على الصعيد
الاقتصادي وهو ما برر به تعديلاته الجديده
سواء على الصعيد المالي او سياسه تويتر
المرتقبه
ماسك اعرابه عن استنكاره للوضع المالي
الحالي ولم يستبعد افلاس الشركه ان لم
تجدد مصادر دخلها
[موسيقى]
ماسك من خساره المليارات سنويا متذرعا بان
الشركه تعتمد على الاعلانات فقط وعلى ضوء
ذلك فرض رسومات جديده على المغردين هي
المخاوف ذاتها التي تتراى لمراقب الوضع
الجديد لتويتر معتبرين ان خطوات ماسك تضع
الطريقه النهايه للعملاق الازرق خاصه مع
تصريح 50% من موظفي الشركه
لتتبعها موجه استقاله من كبار المديرين
التنفيذيين عوامل قد توفر المعلمين على
تويتر ولا تترك لهم اي اسباب في
الاستمراريه
صوره ضبابيه في مستقبل تويتر يحاول ماسك
ان يزيح عنها الغشاوه باجراءات لزياده
الدخل الشركه بينما يرى المراقبون من
الخارج انتحارا الى عمر العربيه